now where'd that batarang go now hand it
over the films and television shows
inspired by dc comics feature plenty of
pristine shiny and stylish props and
costumes so much so that it tempted many
of the stars behind the characters to
take something home with them even if
they weren't always allowed to
everything we tried on i was like okay
if this doesn't end up in the movie
please can i keep it
wonder woman's golden winged costume in
wonder woman 1984 is absolutely stunning
to look at and would likely make for a
good decoration in one's home gal gadot
felt the same way as she took the golden
helmet home with her after filming on
the sequel had wrapped godot claimed
that she normally does not even take
movie props home with her unlike many
other actors but the helmet was just too
meaningful to pass up it's a symbol of
strength of legacy of hope i love having
it with me to remind me of all that only
looks expensive gadot revealed that it's
not actually gold but instead made of
plastic and paint i dare you
birds of prey is filled with plenty of
fashion that made it extremely hard for
harley quinn herself margot robbie to
resist taking home even if it was not
her costume to begin with i took a pair
of shorts that
we didn't actually end up wearing as one
of the costumes but i really liked them
on top of that robbie also took home one
of the tops worn by journey smallet's
black canary though she says that if
smallit wants it back she can have it
despite her fondness of it of course
since she is harley quinn after all
robbie also kept one of the anti-heroes
signature bats because why wouldn't she
once i'm operating strictly on faith not
on reason batman is a character who is
known for being secretive and is able to
get out of situations without leaving a
trace other than his calling card ben
affleck on the other hand was not as
successful as the character he played
when he took home the caped crusaders
iconic batarang while the film's crew
obviously kept track of major props like
the batmobile affleck did not think
anyone would notice if he stole a
batarang i kept getting these phone
calls from the prop department like you
sure you haven't found any of that stuff
yet the crew ended up realizing that
their star brought home a batarang and
even billed him for it batman is
notoriously wealthy so he'll probably be
fine
it activates the ring's higher functions
including a working knowledge base while
we have come to love ryan reynolds as
the merc with a mouth deadpool you may
have forgotten that he once played hal
jordan also known as green lantern
though reynolds would likely want you to
forget about that role
i'm sorry about that reynolds still
wanted to keep a memento from his time
as the intergalactic hero but it was
fairly difficult as there was not as
much to choose from as one might expect
one of the only physical props was of
course the hero's iconic ring which
reynolds ended up bringing home with him
along with marrying his co-star from the
film blake lively
he's a thousand years old and now he's
just an ornament in my living room
journey smallit really bonded with her
cast mates while filming birds of prey
to the point where she ended up taking
home props that didn't necessarily
belong to her character black canary i
got the good night back
don't tell harley not to worry as margot
robbie has a bat of her own as well
smallit also brought home the belly ring
and the nose ring that her character
wore throughout the movie seems like
smallit is just as stylish as black
canary figuring out how to cheat it's
very easy to corrupt
john cena was one of the biggest
highlights of james guns the suicide
squad playing the role of peacemaker
while many actors have been
uncomfortable with their super suits
cena grew up quite fond of them and
ended up taking the costume home with
him cena has even gone as far as to have
worn the costume to various places
including late night talk shows and the
film's red carpet premiere i've learned
that if you just keep the costume on
they don't ask for it back cena was even
able to continue wearing his beloved
toilet seat helmet and red yellow and a
blue suit for the peacemaker spin-off
series though james gunn teased cena
that if he doesn't return the costume
there might not be a second season of
the show
because i ate it okay
ella j bosco was one of the big
breakouts from birds of prey where she
starred as a young cassandra kane a
character who in the comics would go on
to become batgirl bosco had to wear a
pink arm cast for her character which
she started to take a liking to
throughout filming they ended up making
like
15 of them so there's like just take one
bosco even drew all over her casts while
filming to show off her artistic skills
proudly claiming that the cast was her
armor
well you think you can do better
zachary levy has always been very vocal
about being a bit more geek when it
comes to pop culture so playing the hero
shazam was a dream come true to him a
neon sign in the film's strip club scene
ended up catching levy's eye which led
him to start getting ideas if that gets
to live anywhere i wanted to like be in
like my garage or something so that's
that's where it is that's what i took
while levy is mighty proud of his on-set
souvenir from the film he said that he
would likely have to return it should
the production team ever need it again
i'm a natural-born thief so
jason mamoa and ezra miller have shown
just how excited they were to take on
the iconic roles of aquaman and the
flash while these two play superheroes
on screen sometimes it's hard to resist
taking something when it catches your
eye especially in the iconic bat cave
momoa and miller proudly took home what
they claim to be minor props both actors
took home bat bullets which were little
bullets with a tiny red cap on top mamoa
did try to clear the air by revealing
that he ended up giving the sleek prop
to his son
ray fisher has been vocal about his
experience working on justice league but
he still greatly enjoyed working with
zack snyder and the cast so of course an
up-and-coming actor like himself would
want to bring back a keepsake from the
film to show off to his friends and
family and he knew exactly what he
wanted victor's gotham city university
varsity jacket two versions of the
jacket were made for the film and fisher
ended up coaxing the production team to
let him quote on quote borrow one of
them i may let you guys see it one day
but no touching understood
my dad was definitely not into it as a
career choice
zack snyder is one of those directors
who is just as well known as many of the
stars of his movies and he naturally
took advantage of that kind of power he
even made a cameo appearance as a
customer at a cafe alongside ezra
miller's barry allen in the long-awaited
snyder cut of justice league snyder
brought home the painted portrait of
jeffrey dean morgan as batman's father
thomas wayne from the set of batman vs
superman dawn of justice and proudly
hung it up in his home gym consider it a
trophy of sorts meow michelle pfeiffer
was a fan favorite in the role of
batman's seductive rival slash lover
catwoman in the sequel batman returns of
course the feline themed character is
not complete without her trusty whip and
phifer couldn't fight the urge to take
the weapon home with her pfeiffer has
the iconic whip hanging in her closet at
home though she stresses that it can be
very dangerous these things can draw
blood matt ryan won over the hearts of
fans in his portrayal as dc anti-hero
constantine in the nbc series but the
series tragically only lasted one season
fortunately he found second life for the
character in the arrowverse while ryan
wasn't able to grab anything on set
while he was on the set of arrow he did
take a major prop from his debut series
ryan snagged the title character's
lighter which is embossed with some
supernatural etchings i don't use it
though because i lose it batman and
robin is one of the most reviled
superhero movies ever made i hate when
people talk during the movie but that
didn't stop the film's star-filled cast
from wanting to take home many of the
film's neat props including mr freeze
himself arnold schwarzenegger peter
mcgregor scott a producer of the film
revealed that schwarzenegger had to
negotiate with the studio in order to
take home the frosty villains suit which
led them to come to quite the unusual
compromise he had to sign a contract and
i think he pays one dollar per year to
borrow the costume the lights in those
costumes last 9 000 hours he doesn't
have them on all day long but he does
turn them on quite frequently
michael rosenbaum was a hit in the role
of the iconic superman villain lex
luthor in the beloved series smallville
many of rosenbaum's castmates including
clark kent himself tom welling are quite
jealous of rosenbaum's souvenir from set
the white suit worn by lex luthor when
he becomes president
what the hell man it's also cool i'm a
bit of a geek who knows rosenbaum might
need to put on that fancy suit again for
another special occasion
from suits weapons lights casts and more
these dc superhero stars definitely knew
exactly what they wanted from the set of
their films even if they were caught in
the act why would they pass up on the
opportunity to take home a nice looking
prop what's your favorite prop from the
dc universe